[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER: Welcome
to "Google Root Access,"
the show featuring
actionable startup advice.
My guest today is Alex
Haro, co-founder of Life360.
Alex, tell us
about your startup.
ALEX HARO: Sure.
Well, first of all, thank you
so much for having me onboard.
I'm super excited.
Life360 is an app
for families that
lets them see where everyone
is, communicate, coordinate,
keep in touch, and get automated
alerts when their family
members leave work,
arrive home, get
to school, that kind of stuff.
And by focusing
in on that, we've
been able to amass a huge user
base of 44 million families
and growing very quickly.
We're adding an additional
one to two million families
every single month.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, great.
And you should add one
to that one million.
I signed up the other day.
ALEX HARO: Awesome.
Always great to be
talking to a user.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yes.
And so this can actually-- I
haven't started using it yet,
but this app can
actually tell me,
when I'm at work, when my son
leaves school and comes home
to our house?
ALEX HARO: Exactly.
And what we've seen
is those interactions,
a lot of the important
family interactions,
are when they're apart.
The number-one text
message in the world
is still, "Where are you?"
And it's kind of crazy in the
day of smartphones, especially
around families, that they're
still sending those text
messages, "Hey, where are
you?", back and forth.
So we focused in on what are
the really cool interactions
around location?
Automated alerts are one.
We've had some others, like
you can get into your BMW car,
and say, "Drive to my wife," and
it will route you right there.
We can automatically arm
your home security system
when your whole family
leaves the house.
So instead of being this
thing that no one ever uses,
it's this thing you're
using every single day,
thanks to location.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, great.
So I have one concern, though.
Won't this run down the battery
on my phone, my son's phone,
if it keeps running
that GPS chip?
That's a fairly
power-hungry chip, right?
ALEX HARO: Sure.
And I think you're
absolutely right on that.
A lot of apps have tried to
do this, and what they've done
is they've woken the GPS
chip every 10 minutes.
And that absolutely does
kill your battery life.
And what we focused on-- I
mean, we launched back in 2008.
We've really been focused on
how do we get location out
of the phones without
impacting battery?
And luckily, there are
many different sensors
on the phone that give you
location-- things like Wi-Fi,
things like the
cellular networks,
even things like
the accelerometer
and Bluetooth and audio.
All various different
ways to get location
and confirm where people are.
And so we've spent a
lot of time figuring out
what are the right
sensors to turn?
What are the right
tradeoffs to make?
GPS is obviously more
accurate, but more battery.
How do you make those
tradeoffs, and how do you
get awesome location
without killing the battery?
And we've been very
successful doing that.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So I'm an engineer.
I've written a lot of code.
ALEX HARO: Awesome.
MARTIN OMANDER: You have an
engineering background, too.
ALEX HARO: Yes.
MARTIN OMANDER: I can just
imagine massive amounts
of code dealing with various
sensors and various devices,
with various tradeoffs
with battery and accuracy.
How-- that must be a nightmare
to deal with all that.
ALEX HARO: It is a
nightmare, and it
is a lot of tech we've
really had to build.
And as an engineer, I
love the hard stuff.
But we didn't want to be
a location app, right?
We want to provide
awesome stuff to families.
And so you are right.
We've had to deal with
chipset-level bugs
that we've fixed ourselves.
But luckily, Google
has provided a new API
that they call Fused Location.
And what it does is a lot of the
stuff we've been talking about,
where they take all
the various sensors in.
You can tell it, hey, I
care more about accuracy,
or hey, I care
more about battery.
And it just provides you one
interface to get location.
And they've built this on
top of Play Services, which
is really awesome.
And they've also added
things like good geofencing.
The first version of
Android geofencing?
Not very good.
This new version of geofencing,
especially providing
the fused location,
is really good.
And activity
tracking-- so they know
if you're walking,
if you're running,
if you're sitting at home,
if you're driving your car,
or going faster than
the speed of light.
MARTIN OMANDER: Mhm.
How many of your users go
faster than the speed of light?
ALEX HARO: None, too much.
But you know,
let's hope one day.
MARTIN OMANDER: One day.
ALEX HARO: Especially if Elon
Musk gets his way, right?
MARTIN OMANDER: That's right.
So this allows your
developers to work
on sort of higher
abstraction layer level?
They don't have to deal with
the various different chipsets
and such.
ALEX HARO: Exactly.
And one of the
really cool things
is because it's built on
top of the Play Services,
it gets updated when the
Play Services are updated.
So a big debate, especially
in the Android world,
has been fragmentation.
A lot of people have
gone back and forth on
is Android fragmented or not?
And when you're dealing
with the chipsets that
are in specific phones, it
absolutely is fragmented.
But luckily with this
new Fused Location API,
they've been able
abstract around that.
And now, instead of waiting
for Android to be updated,
you just have to tell the
user, update your Google Play
Services, and they automatically
get all the benefits.
When new chipsets come out, that
code is automatically shipped.
When new bugs are found
or new things are fixed,
the API is
automatically upgraded
as part of Google Play
Services instead of
as part of the Android platform.
And that's an awesome
win for users,
and an ingenious move by Google.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right, yeah.
Because my son has had his
phone for a year or two,
and I don't think it's been
upgraded by the carrier once.
ALEX HARO: Exactly.
But with Google
Play Services, he'll
definitely have the newest code.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So Alex, what is your
advice to other startups who
are doing mobile
location-based computing?
ALEX HARO: Sure,
my advice is really
focus in on what you can
build on top of location.
I really would not advise you
to become a location company,
and worry about all
the sensors, and do
a lot of the hard
stuff and heavy lifting
that we had to do.
With these new APIs
around location
that Google has
provided, you can
start to build on
top of location
and offer really cool new
user experiences on top of it.
And that's really what you
should dedicate your time to.
Build on top of these
APIs that exist.
Let Google worry about
the really hard details
around location, and you worry
about the awesome products
that your users want to use.
MARTIN OMANDER: Very good.
Thank you for sharing your
experiences with us, Alex.
ALEX HARO: Absolutely.
Thank you so much.
I had a ton of fun.
MARTIN OMANDER: And
thank you for watching.
We hope you found something
you can use in your startup.
Your input matters.
Please leave your
comments below.
We read everything you write.
To learn how Google
can help your startup,
go to
developers.google.com/startups.
If you would like to
be a guest on the show,
go to bit.ly/applyrootaccess.
That's it for now.
See you next time.